it is the first time since World War two
that people are legitimately believing
that it's okay to go on the street and
incite hatred against a certain
religious group my name is Admiral
Tahiry I was born in Afghanistan I was
raised in Germany and today I live in
Berlin growing up I was never German I
was always the migrant always even if I
tell people I'm German they would still
ask me but no what are you really from
there's a big big problem in German with
subtile racism and a lot of it has to do
with who can claim German identity and
who cannot I think there are a lot of
misconceptions that are going on and
these misconceptions are feeding into
the stereotypes that people have and
then they are using it as a scapegoat
for their own social problems
we want to prove that it's possible to
live together and take the boundaries
that are giving to us and kind of push
them and say no it's not true and prove
other people that it's not true that we
have to that we have to be enemies
savages have misused Islam and the
message of peace